no solo hay muchos tipos de energía sino
que tanto los objetos como los sistemas
pueden tener energía y una vez que
tienen esa energía pueden transferirse
la a otros sistemas u otros objetos o
transformarla a otro tipo de energía
dentro de ese mismo sistema y cuando la
energía se transfiere a eso le llamamos
trabajo la cantidad de trabajo que se
realiza en un sistema es igual a la
cantidad de energía que se transfiere
seguramente has escuchado que la energía
se conserva y eso lo que quiere decir es
que no se puede crear ni destruir nunca
y solo se puede transferir o transformar
entre objetos y sistemas y ahora cuáles
son los tipos de energía pues tenemos la
energía cinética qué es la energía
relacionada con el movimiento y su
fórmula es un medio por masa por
velocidad al cuadrado también tenemos la
energía potencial gravitacional
la energía que tiene un objeto o sistema
gracias a la altura cuya fórmula es masa
por la aceleración debida a la gravedad
por la altura del objeto ahora altura
con respecto a qué bueno pues altura con
respecto a lo que tú decidas que es la
altura cero escoges una línea h igual a
cero y mides de esa altura oye pero eso
no es cómo hacer un poco de trampa no
porque lo que realmente nos importa es
el cambio en energía potencial
gravitacional y no tanto el valor de la
altura y para medir el cambio la altura
específica no importa también tenemos la
energía potencial del resorte que está
relacionada con un resorte que está
comprimido o estirado y su fórmula es un
medio por la constante del resorte por
equis al cuadrado pero mucho cuidado
aquí x no es la longitud del resorte es
que tanto se ha comprimido o estirado
estas tres formas de energía cinética y
potencial son a lo que nosotros llamamos
energía mecánica energía mecánica es
sólo una forma de llamarle a la energía
cinética más la energía potencial
gravitacional más la energía potencial
de resorte en algún sistema pero es muy
importante notar que la energía mecánica
no incluye a la energía térmica la
energía térmica es el calor la energía
generada por fuerzas disipativas como la
fricción o la resistencia del aire y
puedes encontrar la cantidad de energía
térmica generada multiplicando el tamaño
de la fuerza disipativas por la
distancia sobre la que se estuvo
aplicando esa fuerza la unidad de la
energía se llama llull
y la energía no es un vector ahora yo
creo que lo más importante que debemos
recordar acerca de la energía es que si
no hay un trabajo externo sobre un
sistema entonces no hay cambio sobre la
energía de ese sistema en otras palabras
si no hay un trabajo externo sobre un
sistema la energía inicial de ese
sistema va a ser igual a la energía
final del sistema y es con esto con lo
que se resuelven muchísimos problemas de
conservación de la energía pero bueno
ahora vamos a ver un ejercicio que
involucre la energía así es que vamos a
resolver este ejercicio tenemos una caja
esta caja con una velocidad inicial que
se desliza de una plataforma a otra
plataforma más alta por acá y vamos a
suponer que la fuerza de fricción y la
resistencia del aire son despreciables
son tan pequeñas que no las tenemos que
tomar en cuenta
para el sistema que consiste en la masa
de la caja y la tierra que sucede con la
energía mecánica del sistema pero aquí
tenemos que poner mucha atención a en
qué consiste nuestro sistema en este
caso consiste en la masa y la tierra
como nuestro sistema tiene la masa de la
caja que se está moviendo entonces vamos
a tener energía cinética y luego como
tenemos aquí estos dos objetos que están
interactuando gravitacionalmente la masa
de la caja y la tierra entonces también
tenemos la energía potencial
gravitacional y entonces cuando nos
preguntamos por la energía mecánica
total del sistema nos estamos
preguntando por estas dos nos estamos
preguntando qué pasa con la energía
cinética y la energía potencial
gravitacional en total conforme esta
masa se mueve a una altura mayor la
energía potencial gravitacional aumenta
y la caja va a disminuir su velocidad
entonces la energía cinética disminuye
ahora como la caja y la tierra están en
nuestro sistema y la fuerza de fricción
y la resistencia del aire son
despreciables entonces no se está
realizando ningún trabajo externo sobre
nuestro sistema sí es cierto que la
tierra está realizando trabajo sobre la
caja pero la tierra es parte de nuestro
sistema entonces no puede hacer trabajo
externo así es que la energía
simplemente se transforma de una forma a
otra dentro de nuestro sistema y la
energía mecánica total se va a mantener
constante durante todo el trayecto ahora
qué pasa si consideramos el sistema que
consiste únicamente en la caja en este
caso pues tenemos aquí una caja en
movimiento por lo que tenemos energía
cinética pero nuestro sistema ya no
consiste de dos objetos interactuando
gravitacionalmente
entonces ya no tenemos energía potencial
gravitacional dentro de nuestro sistema
y qué sucede con la energía mecánica
total de este sistema bueno pues en este
sistema únicamente tenemos energía
cinética y como la energía cinética
disminuyó entonces la energía total del
sistema disminuyó pero como puede ser
que disminuya
bueno pues disminuye porque ahora la
tierra no es parte de nuestro sistema y
la tierra está realizando un trabajo
sobre la caja pero ahora es un trabajo
exterior que le quita energía a la caja
bueno ahora vamos con lo siguiente vamos
con trabajo que es trabajo en física
trabajo es la transferencia de energía
de un objeto o sistema a otro en otras
palabras si una persona levanta una caja
dándole 10 jules de energía potencial
gravitacional
nosotros decimos que la persona hizo 10
jules de trabajo sobre la caja porque al
final de cuentas la persona le dio 10
jules de energía a la caja y como la
caja tomo de la persona
10 jules de energía decimos que la caja
y son menos 10 jul de trabajo sobre la
persona porque la caja tomó 10 hills de
energía de la persona así es que puedes
encontrar la cantidad de trabajo
realizada si encuentras la cantidad de
energía transferida pero también tenemos
otra alternativa tenemos esta fórmula
para calcular directamente el trabajo si
se está realizando algún trabajo sobre
algún objeto tiene que haber una fuerza
ejerciéndose sobre ese objeto y ese
objeto tiene que ser desplazado así es
que tomamos la fuerza sobre ese objeto
por la distancia que se desplazó ese
objeto y las multiplicamos por el coseno
del ángulo entre la
y el desplazamiento así es que si
queremos encontrar el trabajo una forma
es encontrar la cantidad de energía
transferida pero otra forma de encontrar
el trabajo es tomar la magnitud de la
fuerza ejercida sobre el objeto
multiplicar la por el desplazamiento que
sufre el objeto y multiplicarlo también
por el coseno del ángulo entre la fuerza
y el desplazamiento ahora como el
trabajo es transferencia de energía sus
unidades también son jules ahora si nos
preguntamos si es un vector o no pues no
no es un vector aunque el trabajo si
puede ser positivo o negativo si la
fuerza que se está aplicando sobre el
objeto tiene alguna componente en la
dirección del desplazamiento esa fuerza
está realizando trabajo positivo sobre
el objeto y dándole energía al objeto
por otro lado si la fuerza aplicada
sobre la caja tiene una componente en la
dirección contraria
el trabajo de la fuerza sobre el objeto
sería negativo y la fuerza le estaría
quitando energía y si la fuerza es
perpendicular al movimiento del objeto
la fuerza está haciendo cero trabajo
sobre el objeto ni les está dando
energía ni le está quitando energía
bueno ahora vamos a ver un ejercicio en
donde esté involucrado el trabajo
digamos que una caja de masa m se
desliza hacia abajo sobre una rampa sin
fricción de altura h y con un ángulo de
2 teta
como podemos ver en este diagrama de acá
por otro lado otra caja de masa 2 m se
desliza hacia abajo sobre una rampa sin
fricción de altura h y con un ángulo
theta como podemos ver en este diagrama
de acá y lo que queremos saber es qué
relación tiene el trabajo realizado por
la tierra sobre las dos cajas
este caso la forma más fácil para
encontrar el trabajo es a través del
cambio en energía
cada una de estas cajas va a ganar
energía cinética equivalente a la
energía potencial que pierden el trabajo
realizado por la tierra va a ser igual a
m por g por h
ahora las alturas son exactamente
iguales pero una de las cajas tiene el
doble de masa entonces el trabajo
realizado por la tierra sobre una de las
cajas va a ser el doble que el trabajo
realizado por la tierra sobre la caja
que tiene masa m así es que la tierra
realiza más trabajo sobre la caja 2 m
que nos dice el principio del trabajo y
la energía el principio del trabajo y la
energía nos dice que el trabajo total o
sea el trabajo neto el trabajo neto
sobre un objeto es igual al cambio en la
energía cinética de ese objeto
entonces si sumamos todo el trabajo
realizado sobre un objeto eso tiene que
ser igual al cambio en la energía
cinética del objeto que es igual a un
medio por masa por velocidad final al
cuadrado menos un medio por masa por
velocidad inicial al cuadrado y esta es
una forma muy útil de determinar cómo
cambia la velocidad de un objeto si
podemos determinar la cantidad neta de
trabajo sobre un objeto en otras
palabras si tenemos varias fuerzas
ejerciéndose sobre un objeto si podemos
encontrar la cantidad de trabajo que
están realizando sobre ese objeto
podemos encontrar que tanta energía
cinética ganó o perdió el objeto bueno
ahora vamos a ver un ejercicio acerca
del principio del trabajo y la energía
en este ejercicio tenemos una caja de 4
kilogramos tenemos una caja que se mueve
hacia la izquierda con una velocidad de
6 metros sobre segundo
metros por segundo que hay una caja de 4
kilogramos con velocidad inicial de 6
metros sobre segundo hacia la izquierda
y una cantidad neta de trabajo se
realiza sobre la caja y ahora se mueve
con una velocidad de 4 metros sobre
segundo hacia la derecha ahora la caja
se mueve hacia la derecha y con una
velocidad de 4 metros por segundo y lo
que queremos saber es cuál es la
cantidad neta de trabajo que se realizó
sobre la caja y aquí rápidamente podemos
decir oye como este objeto disminuyó su
velocidad y va a 6 metros sobre segundo
y ahora va a 4 metros sobre segundo el
sistema perdió energía así es que la
cantidad neta de trabajo tiene que ser
negativa por lo que las posibles
opciones son b
o de para averiguar cuál de las dos
opciones es exactamente lo que tenemos
que hacer es recordar el principio de
trabajo de energía que nos dice que la
cantidad de trabajo neto es igual al
cambio en energía cinética así es que
vamos a tomar la energía cinética final
que es un medio por 4 kilogramos de la
caja por la velocidad final que en este
caso son 4 metros sobre segundo y la
velocidad final va a elevada al cuadrado
menos la energía cinética inicial lo
cual es un medio por el peso de la caja
4 kilogramos por la velocidad final 6
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado y esto
si lo calculamos nos da menos 40 jules
entonces es la opción de si nos dan una
gráfica de la fuerza con respecto a la
posición
área entre la curva y el eje de la
posición es el trabajo
así es que siempre que veas una gráfica
de fuerza con respecto a la posición
piensa en el área como el trabajo
realizado pero ten mucho cuidado porque
el área sobre el eje de las x sobre el
eje de la posición representa el trabajo
positivo realizado pero el área entre la
gráfica y el eje de la posición debajo
del eje de la posición representa el
trabajo negativo realizado y aquí
también tienes que tener mucho cuidado
de que el eje de las x realmente
represente la posición del objeto porque
si el eje de las x representa al tiempo
en lugar de representar a la posición
entonces estamos hablando del impulso no
del trabajo pero bueno ahora vamos a
hacer un ejercicio del trabajo
representado como área digamos que una
caja empieza en la posición x igual a 0
con una velocidad de 5 metros sobre
segundo
a la derecha y se le está aplicando una
fuerza neta en dirección horizontal cuya
gráfica podemos encontrar aquí abajo y
lo que queremos saber es en cual
posición distinta a la inicial distinta
a x igual a 0 la caja se vuelve a mover
a 5 metros sobre segundo hacia la
derecha
estamos buscando alguna otra posición en
la que la velocidad final sea igual a la
velocidad inicial ahora como la
velocidad final va a ser igual a la
velocidad inicial entonces el cambio en
energía cinética es igual a cero lo cual
significa que el trabajo neto también va
a ser igual a cero porque el trabajo
neto es igual al cambio en la velocidad
cinética entonces la caja empieza en x
igual a cero y nos estamos preguntando
qué tan lejos nos tenemos que ir como
para que el trabajo neto
igual a 0 entre 0 y 3 metros el trabajo
va a ser negativo porque el área está
bajo el eje de las equis ahora el área
de este triángulo es un medio por base
por altura o sea que es igual a un medio
por la base que son 3 metros 3 metros
por la altura que son menos 6 newtons
menos 6 newtons y esto es igual a menos
9 jules y ahora el área de este
triángulo el trabajo positivo que se
hace entre 3 y 5 metros también tiene un
área de un medio por base por altura lo
cual es igual a un medio por 2 metros de
base por 2 metros por 2 newtons de
altura por 2 newtons de altura así es
que tenemos más
4 jules de trabajo realizado por lo que
cuando la caja llega a la posición x 5
se ha realizado un trabajo neto de menos
9 jules + 4 jules las pies que en esta
posición el trabajo realizado es igual a
menos 5
jules pero lo que nosotros queremos es
que el trabajo neto sea igual a cero así
es que tenemos que seguir en esta
dirección hasta que la cantidad de
trabajo positivo realizado sea igual a
la cantidad de trabajo negativo
realizado en otras palabras si logro que
toda el área negativa sea igual al área
positiva estaré logrando que el trabajo
neto sea igual a cero y haber mi área
negativa son menos 9 jules y el área
positiva hasta acá son 4 jules
y me sigo hasta la posición x4 hasta acá
nada más nos faltará a sumar esta
cantidad de trabajo que son otros 4
jules positivos porque la altura de este
rectángulo son 4 newtons y la base mide
un metro así es que hasta este punto
tenemos menos 9 jules + 4 jules + 4
jules así es que nos falta únicamente un
joule para que el trabajo neto sea igual
a cero nosotros ya no necesitamos llegar
hasta 7 metros
necesitamos simplemente un cuarto de
este metro para obtener un joule
positivo más de trabajo y entonces ahora
si un joule + 4 jules más otros 4 jules
son igual a 9 jules más los menos 9
jules del principio ahora si el trabajo
neto ya es igual a 0 por lo que el
trabajo neto va a ser igual a 0 en algún
punto entre x 6 y x igual a 7
así como en esa posición en esta
posición el trabajo neto va a ser igual
a cero entonces la energía cinética
también va a ser igual a cero y por lo
tanto la velocidad inicial y la
velocidad final van a ser iguales que
significa potencia potencia es la
cantidad de trabajo realizado por unidad
de tiempo así es que también podemos
pensar en la potencia como la cantidad
de energía transferida trabajo por
unidad de tiempo en otras palabras la
cantidad de jules por segundo que son
transferidos y a los soles por segundo
les llamamos watts así es que podemos
pensar en la potencia como la cantidad
de trabajo entre el tiempo o sea la
cantidad de energía transferida entre el
tiempo que nos tardamos en transferirla
y podemos aumentar la potencia
aumentando la cantidad de trabajo
realizado
o disminuyendo la cantidad de tiempo que
nos tardamos en hacer el mismo trabajo
al igual que la energía y el trabajo la
potencia no es un vector pero bueno como
siempre ahora vamos a ver un ejercicio
que involucra potencia tenemos una caja
con masa m que se desliza hacia abajo
por una rampa sin fricción de altura h y
con ángulo 2 t está tenemos ese diagrama
por acá y luego tenemos aquí otro
diagrama otra caja también de masa m que
se desliza hacia abajo por una rampa sin
fricción también de altura h pero ahora
con un ángulo theta y este diagrama lo
tenemos por acá y lo que queremos saber
es cómo se relacionan las potencias
promedio generadas por la fuerza de
gravedad sobre cada una de las cajas en
estas dos pendientes empecemos por aquí
poniendo la fórmula de la potencia la
potencia es el trabajo entre el tiempo
el tiempo que nos tomó realizar ese
abajo ahora el trabajo realizado sobre
cada una de estas cajas es igual al
cambio en energía cinética pero el
cambio en energía cinética es igual al
cambio en energía potencial así es que
este trabajo es igual a la masa por la
aceleración de la gravedad por el cambio
de altura y aquí estamos dividiendo
entre el tiempo este es el cambio en
energía potencial de las cajas ahora
entre estas dos cajas hay muchas
similitudes la masa se mantiene
constante la constante de aceleración de
la gravedad se mantiene constante la
altura pues están en rampas de la misma
altura entonces el trabajo realizado
sobre las cajas es igual sin embargo el
tiempo que le toma a cada una de estas
cajas en deslizarse hasta abajo es
distinto para cada caja esta caja en la
rampa más inclinada va a llegar al fondo
más rápido y entonces la potencia en
ésta
ajá va a ser mayor si la comparamos con
la potencia de esta caja que se tarda
más en deslizarse hasta abajo de la
rampa por lo que se genera una potencia
mayor en la pendiente de ángulo 2 teta
porque aunque se esté realizando
exactamente la misma cantidad de trabajo
la velocidad con la que se realiza este
trabajo es mucho mayor en la rampa que
está más inclinada en comparación con la
rampa menos inclinada